with the rapid development in the
information technology sector it is
imperative that we keep ourselves
updated so here we are to help you with
that today we will be discussing the top
10 trending tech courses for 2022 so if
you're looking to start your career in
top tech companies or want a career
switch here's a list of tech courses
that you should watch out for in 2022 it
is good to go for courses that offer
certifications as it offers a way for
you to prove to potential employers that
you have the skills you say you do the
10th course on our list is web
development
web development is all about building
and maintaining websites it includes
aspects such as web design web
programming and web publishing
the skills you will learn in this course
are html css javascript bootstrap react
and more using this set of technologies
will enable you to create high quality
interactive websites that are compatible
with several types of devices the
average salary for this domain ranges
between sixty two thousand dollars to
one fifty eight thousand dollars in the
us
and thirteen point seven lakh to thirty
lakh rupees in india some of the best
companies hiring web developers are
amazon tcs thompson reuters general
dynamics and ibm
now coming to the ninth course we have
cyber security the onset of the kovit 19
pandemic has brought about a new digital
revolution
this has also been a catalyst for the
increase in the number of cyber crimes
across the globe to keep cyber crimes in
check and protect crucial data
organizations are on the lookout for
cyber security professionals now more
than ever
a good cyber security course will
further help you to work as a network
administrator systems administrator i.t
manager security engineer security
consultant etc a network engineer or
cyber security expert earns
approximately eighty four thousand
dollars to one sixty four thousand
dollars per annum in the united states
and five land to forty lakh rupees in
india pwc hcl accent choco forge and
deloitte are some of the top companies
hiring cyber security experts now the
next course we have on our list is the
big data course companies and internet
users across the world are generating
enormous amounts of data every day by
2025 there will be 175 zettabytes of
data collected globally with tremendous
job opportunities and hiring big data
analysts being a top priority in a lot
of organizations a career in big data
would be an ideal choice for you by
enrolling in a big data course you will
learn big data frameworks such as hadoop
and the real-time processing framework
apache spark you will also gain
expertise in nosql based technologies
like mongodb cassandra and hedgebase
apart from these you will also learn
tools such as hive and pig with these
skills you can become a big data
developer big data analyst or a big data
consultant a big data engineer can earn
121 thousand dollars to 251 000 per
annum in the united states
in india he or she can earn close to
12.3 lakh to 33 lakh rupees per annum
with the right certification with big
data skills you can try for companies
such as walmart dell cognizant cisco and
american express coming to the seventh
course in the list of top 10 tech
courses we have blockchain developer
blockchain's popularity grew with the
rise of bitcoin prices as per indeed.com
the success of the cryptocurrency
industry has resulted in 118 jump in
career postings for blockchain jobs
compared to last year by learning
blockchain you'll understand how
blockchain technology works ethereum
solidity hyperledger smart contracts and
learn to build production ready apps you
will understand the blockchain
architecture and what it takes to
implement the individual blockchain
components into a unified system you
will also gain exposure to research and
evaluate new tools and technologies and
integrate them into a blockchain network
a blockchain developer could earn 125
000 to 185 thousand 250 dollars in the
united states and 6 lakh to 14 lakh
rupees per annum in india jp morgan kpmg
microsoft and usd global are a few
companies that are actively hiring
blockchain developers
up next we have the digital marketing
course
digital marketing is a precious asset to
a business's growth both large and small
and helps to establish an absolute
online presence with digital marketers
companies can reach a global audience in
a way that's cost effective scalable and
measurable they can help you monitor
your campaigns and optimize them for
better results and find out what your
competitors are doing online a good
digital marketing course will help you
learn seo scm web analytics social media
marketing content marketing and email
marketing with these skills you can
implement powerful and cost effective
ways to promote your business to its
target audience a digital marketing
manager could earn 60 000 to 160 000 in
the united states and 7 lakh to 16 lakh
rupees per annum in india google zoho
times internet myntra and wipro digital
are actively hiring digital marketing
professionals in the fifth place we have
the very popular python programming
course python is one of the most widely
used programming languages in the iit
industry as of february 2021 python was
the most popular programming language
based on how regularly its tutorials
were searched on google with a 30.06
percent market share the python course
will help you learn the basics of python
programming such as data structures
loops and functions you will understand
the essential object-oriented
programming concepts along with advanced
topics such as file handling modules and
packages python graphical user interface
as well as important libraries like
numpy and pandas after completing this
course you can apply for python
developer web developer data analyst and
data scientist types of job roles a
python developer could earn 109 000 to
180 000 in the united states and 4 lakh
to 10 lakh rupees per annum in india
some of the best companies you can look
out for a career in python are spotify
facebook flipkart big basket and
capgemini moving to the next top 10 tech
courses we have project management as
per a global survey conducted by pwc 97
of organizations believe that using the
right project management methodology is
crucial in ensuring business success the
demand for project management jobs is
estimated to reach nearly 90 million by
2027.
if you want to manage a successful
project even with zero experience in
that industry then a pmp certification
course is a must it will help you
achieve the project management knowledge
and skills required to manage an entire
project on your own you will learn how
to plan manage execute and control
projects you will also gain experience
in popular project management
methodologies that help organizations
deliver successful projects with a
proper certification a project manager
can make 75 000 to 144 000 per year in
the united states and 12 lakh to 17 lakh
rupees per year in india some of the top
companies to grow your career as a
project manager are amazon oracle united
health group accenture and boston
consulting group coming to the third
course we have data science there is a
huge abundance of data however there
aren't enough skilled professionals to
convert this data into useful
information data scientist is one of the
highly paid jobs in the world being a
successful data scientist needs more
than just knowing how to make sense of
big sets of data you also need to
understand business issues and how to
address them with analytical solutions
so if you're looking for a career in
data science then sign up for a course
that covers all the in-demand data
science skills such as programming
statistics data visualization
exploratory data analysis and machine
learning with these skills you can
impress interviewers by showing your
exposure to the data science field and
applying data science to real-life
business cases by choosing the right
certification a data scientist can earn
up to 115 000 to 246 000 in the united
states and 8.2 lakh to 20 lakh rupees in
india gramina uber intel twitter and
paypal are a few companies that you
should consider for a career in data
science
second on the list we have ai and
machine learning courses ai and machine
learning are two of the biggest and most
popular technologies of the 21st century
ai and machine learning have found their
applications in healthcare retail
entertainment e-commerce manufacturing
logistics as well as the aerospace
industry ai and machine learning jobs
are highly in demand and it is the skill
of the century by enrolling in this
course you will be trained in machine
learning algorithms deep learning
artificial neural networks as well as
natural language processing after
gaining all the crucial skills you can
now build smart systems and devices that
can mimic human intelligence an ai
engineer can earn hundred and forty
thousand dollars to three hundred and
eighty six thousand dollars in the
united states and six lakh to 20 lakh
rupees in india
top companies hiring machine learning
and ai engineers are google adobe
qualcomm sprinkler and fidelity
investments
finally at number one in the list of top
10 trending tech courses for 2022 we
have cloud computing between 2020 and
2021 cloud computing erupted as work
went virtual and businesses adapted to
the global pandemic according to
statista.com the worldwide public cloud
computing market is expected to reach an
estimated 482 billion us dollars in
2022. cloud computing professionals not
only improve how businesses store and
access data but are also transforming
how businesses operate a cloud computing
course will walk you through the general
cloud computing concepts and give a
solid foundation of cloud computing
platforms such as aws microsoft azure
and google cloud platform once you
become a certified cloud expert you can
help companies store data efficiently
with easy access and a higher level of
security you can also assist companies
to recover data swiftly a cloud
computing engineer can earn up to 145
000 to 227 000 in the united states and
earn close to 16 lakh to 24 lakh rupees
in india with the right certification
wipro pwc oracle netapp and abb are some
of the best companies that are hiring
for cloud computing so that was our list
of top 10 trending tech courses for
2022. on that note we would like to tell
you that simplylearn offers courses and
certifications for all the technologies
mentioned above and the links to it will
be added in the description below do
check it out so do you agree with our
top 10 list or do you think we missed
out on any then please let us know in
the comment section below
we hope these courses will help you grow
in your career in the field of your
choice and interest thank you for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here